while our CBS team is covering the
summit between President Trump and Kim
jong-un we want to reflect on how the
Vietnam War changed broadcast news
forever
it was the first time war coverage was
broadcast on American televisions at
home CBS News is among those who brought
the front lines to the US CBS Evening
News anchor Jeff Glor is in Hanoi with
pivotal moments from the Vietnam War
captured by our reporters Jeff good
morning John good morning back to you
before Vietnam visual reports of war
were often censored information from
propaganda played for example in movie
theaters and Beyond television changed a
lot of that and the people who built CBS
News led the charge they are the first
actual ground combat troops to enter the
country on March 8th 1965 cameras were
rolling as US Marines landed in Danai
they were combat ready as they landed
for the first time on a regular basis
news from the frontlines made its way
into living rooms across America we are
wearing these black vests Walter
Cronkite gave us a look from the sky oh
I know something I want those astronauts
must go through more every day getting a
feel of the country Morley Safer
documented the sounds and we were
walking into this village when you're
gonna hear what happened in people's
this is what the war in Vietnam is all
about
the old in the very odd the horror on
the ground realities of war - thus
postions more than 58,000 Americans were
killed over two decades during the
Vietnam War including those who covered
it 9 CBS News employees died 33 others
were wounded there's six men in this
small trench and two of the men wounded
one a CBS sound technician Edie Bradley
was hit by gun shrapnel John Lawrence's
crew faced angry police while trying to
cover student protests six employees of
CBS News were clubbed beaten and driven
back by police the plane raced down the
taxiway toward the end this one of the
most unforgettable moments in News
history the stampede of terrorized
people tried to storm the plane Bruce
Dunning's 1975 report on the last plane
out of Danang as the city fell to North
Vietnamese troops as men clamored over
one another pushing aside women and
children in their panic-stricken fury
members of the air crew dragged them
onto the plane trying to fill it as fast
as possible deserters shoved and shot
their way onto a plane meant for women
and children as calm fell on the SMUD
man who had managed to fight off their
friends and relatives to get on the
hard-working cabin crew took account 268
people were on board
among them five women and two or three
small children
when that plane landed in Saigon people
poured out of the luggage hold some
Vietnam veterans are returning here
during this historic week we met with
them in Ho Chi Minh City recently an
astonishing group of more than 50 they
have come back to Vietnamese soil for
the first time in five decades their
stories are heartbreaking they are also
hopeful we will meet with them on
tonight's CBS Evening News the auto back
stories are so important to tell as well
Jeff Glor thank you so much for bringing
that important piece to our viewers and
a reminder of the dangers and so many
reporters go through around the world to
bring everyone coverage of what's taking
place